monsieur mig bienvenue sur arte france
merci d'être avec nous on vient de le
dire les états unis inculpé maduro de
narco terrorisme sur quoi se basent
style pour l'accusée ainsi c'est une
bonne question mais malheureusement ne
comptez pas sur moi pour vous apporter
une réponse source et car c'est une
vieille rengaine des états unis n'y
d'accuser le gouvernement bolivarien de
trafiquants de drogue international il
se trouve que l'épreuve mans qui en fait
les états unis pour établir leur dossier
se base sur les déclarations de
d'anciens fonctionnaires de l'état
vénézuélien qui eux mêmes étaient sous
le coup de sanctions des etats-unis donc
en fait c'est à dire que lorsque la
personne livre un témoignage à charge
contre le gouvernent des membres de
l'état vénézuélien
les sanctions contre elle sont levés
donc en réalité ce n'est pas très
sérieux comme enquête policière
alors concrètement qu'est ce qui se
passe actuellement au venezuela on sait
que mme haddour est soutenue par la
russie par la chine par cuba on sait que
gaido lui est soutenu par les états unis
1 en première ligne est également 60
autres pays de la communauté
internationale actuellement qui dirige
le venezuela
écoutez je pense que c'est clair les
images que vous montrez derrière moi le
montre bien il n'y a qu'un seul
gouvernement bien entendu j'aurais juste
rajouté une petite précision à ce que
vous venez de dire nicolás maduro est
soutenu aussi par le peuple vénézuélien
ce qui n'est pas rien non démocratie
n'est ce pas grande majorité du peuple
vénézuélien le soutien et une un secteur
non négligeable de l'opposition le
reconnaît aussi comme chef d'état la
crise du coc vide
19 le montre bien nicolás maduro a
déclaré la quarantaine avec toute une
série de mesures très progressiste pour
permettre aux gens de vivre leur
confinement dans une situation descente
et les secteurs de l'opposition s'y sont
attelés ce qui montre bien le leadership
du chef de l'état vénézuélien
je voudrais juste
nir sur un détail cette accusation de
washington vient en fait comme une des
mesures de plus contre le venezuela qui
ont lieu ces jours ci car figurez vous
que pendant la pandémie
la guerre contre le venezuela continue
hier des camps de mercenaires ont été
démantelés dans le nord du pays et deux
camps de mercenaires sont de l'autre
côté de la frontière en colombie le
blocus économique et financier contre le
venezuela a été renforcée le 12 mars par
les états unis avec des sanctions contre
l'entreprise pétrolière russe pnk
internationale et il ya aussi une guerre
médiatique qu'on voit enfin bon qu'on
voit partout mais c'est super eagles en
chantant en allemand
pardon oui et de travail et nous on n'a
plus beaucoup de temps je voulais
revenir avec vous sur le fmi car j'étais
récemment une aide de 5 milliards de
dollars qu'avait demandé nicolás maduro
justement pour lutter contre le
coronavirus clairement le fmi l'a appris
par a pris partie en tout cas pour les
états unis
vous savez quand même que le les
etats-unis sont le principal financier
du fmi il serait qui ont le plus de
pourcentage de de quote-part de décision
donc ce n'est pas évidemment hasard
le porte parole du fmi a dit que ce
n'était pas clair qui dirigeait au
venezuela pour le fmi bon évidemment là
on est dans le show politique je crois
que il faut le lire ça différemment je
pense que les autorités de caracas était
consciente que le fmi allait rejeter
leur demande mais cela constitue
désormais une preuve pour le
la l'interpellation pour la plainte qu'a
portes qu'à poser le venezuela au
tribunal pénal international contre les
sanctions et le blocus des états unis
contre ce pays donc évidemment la 7e
refus de l'efféminé plus anodins ou
médiatique
romain ami gus merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste du venezuela